what fascinates you i like people that
are worth hundreds of millions of
dollars
right you like i mean it's just what it
is it doesn't mean that i'm
i'm it doesn't mean that i'm like a part
of that or ever will be or and
that's i need not even say that but i
just
it's not an area that i'm not going to
be kept up at night by bay ridge but i'm
not kept up at night by where i grew up
right
where do you want to where what keeps
you up at night yeah
yeah fifth avenue park avenue yeah yeah
is that the bronx compared to no i mean
beverly hills yeah i mean in
in terms of taste yes but there's some
real money over there yeah there's some
real money over there
uh you know pollock's path in hong kong
yeah
keeps me up one hyde park in london yeah
those just see it's interesting
i just like to know you know i said to
ben my my producer
we were eating who's on the hot seat
yeah he's on the hot seat better he
better figure it out yeah because
homeless pimp's coming pimp's coming i'm
going to take pimp and i'm not going to
pay you but you're going to meet whitney
cummings
so the whole thing is you're going to
inject botox into the wooden coming's
ass
here's the whole thing and it's better
than money so the reaction we're gonna
we're gonna release this so we gotta i
don't care she doesn't care she's a
comic
okay she's the only comic in l.a right
now not in jail r p here's the point
this is what i'm saying uh what i'm
saying is that
it's i just a very interested like i
just started i looked at ben we're
eating
a little strawberry oreo ice cream at
john's and montauk well done
and i said it's got to be funny to make
a billion dollars
we just started laughing yeah i said
it's just to make a billion
dollars is funny yeah it's like [ __ ]
it's
funny yeah there's something about it
that like i just
i just start laughing when i think of a
guy
with a billion dollars i just start
laughing right he never has to hear like
yeah his wife go i want to do this
and he he never has to hear himself go
i'm not sure if we can afford that you
know what it is people have such vastly
different experiences on planet earth
vastly different almost that we're like
a different species
it really is and yeah and that's good
that's an alt-right dog whistle i
appreciate that because they do spend
the money
and uh no but it it really
truly is and like to me i look at those
waspy people in the hamptons
that people have made you've been rich
for centuries been rich for so
long and uh they're a little different
they're just a little different the way
they act as little they smell good they
have a scent the honest talks about pie
they're always smell good yeah even when
they sweat they can't they just
they they have the them and like jasmine
yeah yeah
yeah they don't sweat they smell like
lavender or or the interesting things
you know
they're not working they're not workers
right
they're not even seeing even when they
exercise if you see that equinox
whatever they don't see
that smell yeah but it's because they
they're not they're not bred
to be like work they're like they've
kind of always sat
at the top right yeah right right i said
a quote once that
i really related to the guy don't do
things for the moral of the story i do
them for the story
right you see it's got to be fun it's
got to be fun
it's just a lot of fun you want it's got
to be fun right because guess what
cocaine was fun right sure so if i'm not
going to do that
i got to have fun right it's got to be
fun right
i look at so many people that are so
much more successful than me but they
don't have any fun yeah like it was fun
like we're walking today in bay ridge
it's a beautiful hot day we walk
you know we walk past car valley said
you want to jump in there and team says
no i got to be good and then we get
about five more feet he says let's go
hit the carvel let's just look
right back and guess what it was fun
it was fun it was fun it was fun it's
funny because for the economy the people
going to be on the street
yeah and all these people are kicking a
little money people say oh somebody got
corona they can't run marathons anymore
good [ __ ] them
what is them running marathons do for
the economy i go out to eat twice a day
let's get real
let's stop pretending that run the
american economy is not fueled by
running
you know when you're lucky there's this
idea of of and our economy is built on
this model of perpetual growth
right everything's got to be bigger and
bigger and bigger the house has got to
be bigger
the pool's got to be deeper the yard has
got to be bigger the debt is going to be
bigger
you got to know when to hand you got to
know when you've got to know when to
cash in it's the disease of more
right the disease of more and it's and
it was those wall street guys weren't
poor
before they started slinging these
things they weren't poor but they got
you know in the last 10 or 15 20 years
people in that line of work have gotten
astronomically
wealthy a level of wealthy that most
people don't understand
i'm talking about many of them are
earning a billion
dollars in a calendar year or over a
hundred million dollars in a calendar
year right not 30 million not a million
a month not 2 million a month not 5
million a month
we're talking in cases 20 30 million
dollars a month the guys at the top of
those institutions
they've become so [ __ ]
like dislocated from the city there is a
real
[ __ ] like you know problem
with that type of money so on the
deepest level
it was the disease of more on the side
of those who are
getting the loans and on the side of the
people who are giving the law correct
right it's all across the board it's the
american dream
and i knew it was over when i was in a
diner in the same diner i said to the
waiter i said um
hey you know my order at the diner is
always mozzarella sticks
also i'd like a grilled cheese with
turkey because i'm i'm turning over
noodles and then i asked the waitress
where's the closest carvel
yeah grilled cheese with turkey tomato
i'm turning over new leaf i didn't say
bacon i'd say turkey
now let me ask you a question if bacon
goes in the sandwich
with the turkey
[Laughter]
[Music]
coleslaw french fries lightly cooked but
don't burn them don't give me the don't
give me the excuse that people aren't
paying attention in there
so and uh so i said uh
i said to the waiter he goes what do you
guys do i said i do mortgages he goes
what a coincidence i do mortgages
and then the guy who's handed me my
mozzarella sticks took out a card from
his top pocket and put it on the diner
table
and that's kind of the way i felt you
know about a year or a year and a half
ago in comedy when everyone you knew was
it met was a comedian
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
ridge patreon.comridgeboys where things
get really wild